In rare cases, a truly terrible performance
can actually improve a movie, transforming
the mediocrity on display into something so
bad that it turns full circle and becomes
great in its own right, or at least enjoyable.
Join us as we take a look at the dreadful
roles that might never win an Oscar, but that
actually managed to make a film better.
Everyone's favorite flower shop customer typifies
the kind of bad acting that people enjoy more
than any other.
"Hi, doggie."
"You're my favorite customer."
"Thanks a lot.
Bye."
After writing, directing, and starring in
2003's truly inexplicable The Room, a film
often described as the Citizen Kane of bad
movies, Tommy Wiseau became an industry legend
in ways that even he couldn't predict.
Fifteen years after Wiseau made his big screen
debut, the actor's bizarre accent, exaggerated
delivery, and sheer lack of acting ability
have transformed The Room into a cult classic
that continues to be quoted by midnight movie
fans worldwide.
In the hands of anyone else, a script like
this would just be bad, but Wiseau's baffling
performance somehow elevates these words into
a bizarrely hilarious curio that will forever
hold a place in Hollywood's hall of fame.
"You're lying, I never hit you.
You are tearing me apart, Lisa!"
In the end, Wiseau's performance was so bad
that it wound up inspiring an entire award-winning
movie.
In 2017, James Franco starred as Wiseau in
The Disaster Artist, a movie based on the
making of The Room, affecting his own inexplicable
accent and picking up a Golden Globe for his
troubles.
That's one of the few times that anyone's
been given an award for being good at bad
acting.
Sometimes, a movie deserves every bit of its
bad reputation, and 1995's allegedly erotic
thriller Showgirls is definitely not great.
According to director Paul Verhoeven, however,
that was always the intent.
Elizabeth Berkley, who starred as Nomi Malone,
deliberately pushed her trashiness to previously
unseen extremes precisely because he told
her to, in an effort to deliver exactly the
kind of performance that he felt that the
script from Joe Eszterhaus required.
"Well it ain't right.
You got too much TALENT for it to be right!"
"Get outta here!"
While critics trashed the movie when it hit
theaters, audiences have since learned to
embrace the ludicrous dialogue and campy acting
of Showgirls, holding a particularly special
place in their hearts for Berkley and the
way she played Nomi.
From her cringeworthy attempts at dancing
to that infamous scene in the swimming pool,
Berkley's performance has become one of the
all-time greats in cult cinema.
It's just a shame that her attempts to turn
people on ultimately turned casting directors
off.
In an effort to distance herself from the
good girl she'd played on Saved by the Bell,
Berkley wound up tanking her acting career
at what could've been its height.
After returning to the spotlight with his
iconic role in Quentin Tarantino's Pulp Fiction
in 1994, John Travolta could've done just
about anything.
Unfortunately, what he decided to do with
his new-found glory and millions of his own
dollars was produce a sci-fi epic that became
one of the most notorious flops in cinema
history.
Based on a novel written by L. Ron.
Hubbard, the founder of Scientology, Battlefield
Earth became a legendary failure for both
audiences and fans.
Virtually every aspect of the film was panned,
with critics condemning everything from the
confused direction to the ludicrous plot holes,
but particular attention was given to Travolta's
role in the film.
"With endless options for renewal!
With endless options for renewal!
HAHAHA!"
The long-time Scientologist played Terl, a
member of the Psychlos, Battlefield Earth's
ten foot-tall world-conquering aliens who
kept "man-animals" as slaves to turn a profit
for a space corporation.
Short of twiddling an imaginary moustache,
Travolta's pantomime performance went so far
over the top that it became the only thing
in a movie that was otherwise mind-bogglingly
monotonous that was actually fun to watch.
"While you were still learning how to SPELL
your name, I was being trained to conquer
galaxies!"
Despite its now legendary critical mauling,
Travolta still maintains that Battlefield
Earth is actually an underrated classic that
doesn't deserve its bad reputation.
He's even claimed in interviews that if he
had to do it all over again, he'd still take
the role, blaming the media for its negative
image.
Sounds like he really did want those endless
options for renewal after all.
In a misguided attempt to recapture the campy
magic of the '60s Batman TV show, director
Joel Schumacher and writer Akiva Goldsman
set the superhero genre back decades with
their second collaboration starring the Dark
Knight.
From its gaudy production values to those
unforgettable bat-nipples, Batman & Robin
has regularly topped lists compiling the worst
movies of all time since its release in 1997.
Both Schumacher and star George Clooney have
even apologized for their roles in bringing
the film to life, regretting how Batman & Robin
temporarily brought the franchise to an end
before it was rebooted eight years later.
However, anyone who's seen the film knows
that no apology is necessary.
It might have some pretty significant flaws,
but it's a movie that knows exactly what it
wants to be, and also brought us the campy
delight that is Arnold Schwarzenegger in the
role of Mr. Freeze.
"Show some mercy!"
"MERCY?!
I'm afraid that my condition has left me cold."
In a huge departure from the more serious
action roles that he was known for, like Terminator
and Predator, Schwarzenegger's take on the
ice cold villain took action movie puns to
the next level.
"What killed the dinosaurs?
The ice age!"
Freeze takes great delight in turning every
line into a gag, and, in hindsight, it's hard
to imagine anyone else but Arnie managing
to get through any of it without either breaking
into laughter or bailing on the film entirely.
1987's big-screen adaptation of Masters of
the Universe was Inspired by the beloved '80s
cartoon and toy line, mixing Mattel's story
of He-Man and Eternia with elements from unrelated
comics by Jack Kirby, the co-creator of the
Marvel Universe.
Given He-Man's popularity and how much people
have turned out to love Kirby's creations
in their massive cinematic universe, that
probably seems like a good idea for a blockbuster
franchise.
It was not.
"I, Skeletor, am Master of the Universe."
Poor reviews and lackluster box office earnings
put an end to hopes for a sequel, and even
contributed to the imminent closure of B-movie
icon Cannon Films, but it seems that most
people missed the point.
Sure, He-Man's ongoing war against Skeletor
is clunky and poorly made, but Masters Of
The Universe also deserves to be celebrated
as a campy classic in its own right, mostly
due to Dolph Lundgren's performance in the
lead role.
"I'll never kneel to you!"
"Yes you will!
Yes you will!"
Wielding a sword and little else, Lundgren
imbued He-Man with a goofy charm that resonated
with an entire generation of children who
were overjoyed to see their hero on the big
screen at last.
Using any measure known to man, it's clear
that Lundgren's performance will never be
considered as "good" in any objective interpretation
of the word, but his portrayal of the character
on screen has made what could've been a forgotten
toy tie-in into a fascinating cult classic.
Like Robin Hardy's original 1973 take on The
Wicker Man, the 2006 remake revolves around
the search for a missing girl on a remote
island.
However, unlike the first Wicker Man film,
the newer version starring Nicolas Cage omits
the horror in favor of unintentionally hilarious
comedy, spawning hundreds of snarky reviews
from critics and countless more memes from
the internet at large.
"How'd it get burned?
How'd it get burned?
How'd it get burned?"
Viewed purely as a remake of the horror classic,
the 2006 version of The Wicker Man is definitely
not a good film.
After all, the original remains a masterclass
in suspense and paranoia, and this new imitation
simply doesn't hold up.
However, if you're willing to put aside any
notions of horror and embrace Cage's bizarre
performance for what it is, then the new Wicker
Man is arguably one of the best comedies ever
made.
"Oh, what is that?!
What is it?!
OH, NO NOT THE BEES!
NOT THE BEES!
AHHHH!
AH THEY'RE IN MY EYES!"
It's hard to tell whether Cage played the
part for laughs or was genuinely sincere in
the role, but either way, his (over-)acting
here is truly a marvel to behold.
With an animal-like intensity, Cage blazes
across the screen, screaming about bees and
punching women while wearing a bear costume.
There's nothing else out there quite like
it, and if the film's box office failure is
anything to go by, then there will probably
never be anything like this again.
It's rather ironic that a movie about a futuristic
cop that acts as judge, jury, and executioner
has become a guilty pleasure for many, but
that's exactly what's happened in the years
since Sylvester Stallone brought Judge Dredd
to the big screen in 1995.
"Drop your weapons!
These blocks are under arrest!"
The film was originally considered to be a
box office flop domestically, and since it
lacked the satirical tone and stern, stone-faced
scowl of the original British comic book character,
it didn't resonate with casual moviegoers
or die-hard fans of 2000 AD.
For that, fans would have to wait another
17 years, but interest in the property has
ensured that Stallone's Judge Dredd will never
be forgotten completely.
One particular sticking point for fans of
the comic was the fact that Stallone took
off the helmet and revealed Dredd's face in
the movie.
This is something that the character would
have never done in the source material, and
still hasn't in over 40 years of comics.
Then again, if Stallone hadn't wanted to get
his mug on camera, we would have never received
the gift of his hilariously goofy facial expressions.
"For Judge Joseph Dredd."
"It's a lie!
The evidence has been falsified!
It's impossible!
I never broke the law!
I am the law!"
The sheer absurdity peaks at the end of the
film, during an argument shared between Dredd
and his evil clone, Rico, escalating to the
point where both forget how to pronounce basic
words in English.
"You killed innocent people!"
"The means to an end!"
"You started a massacre!"
"I was the revolution!"
"You betrayed the law!"
"LAWWWWW!"
The gibberish that both actors scream at each
other has since become immortalized online
thanks to an endless stream of parodies that
ensure Judge Dredd will hold a special place
in the hearts of cinephiles everywhere.
Plus, we got a much more accurate adaptation
simply titled Dredd in 2012 that did a far
better job of capturing what the character
is really all about, making Stallone's cinematic
failure a lot easier for fans to take.
In the same tradition as The Beatles' A Hard
Day's Night in 1964 and The Monkees' cult
film Head in 1968, The Spice Girls brought
their own unique brand of girl power to cinemas
everywhere in 1997, capitalizing on both their
record-breaking success and the world's brief
fascination with "Cool Britannia."
Predictably, Spice World broke box office
records, and, even more predictably, the critics
loathed it for the most part.
However, even the most hardened journalist
must admit that there's something infectiously
fun about the film.
Sure, there's not much of a plot to speak
of and, yes, none of the girls ever made the
headlines for their acting ability, but thanks
to the bubbly charisma of the stars and a
roster of wild cameos that includes Elvis
Costello and Meat Loaf in a minor role, Spice
World continues to spice up the lives of fans
everywhere two decades on.
Spice World even got a re-release in U.K.
cinemas to celebrate its 20th anniversary
in 2017, suggesting that the Spice Girls still
retain their retro charm.
Since Spice World was first released, the
girls have gone their separate ways and reunited
more than once, but none of that matters while
watching the film.
Spice World is a bright and breezy time-capsule
of a unique period in pop music history, one
that wouldn't work without the brash positivity
of the girls themselves, each of whom elevate
the plot's silly trappings into something
undeniably silly yet ultimately engrossing.
Every now and again, a movie comes along that
defies the odds and fails in every conceivable
way.
More than any other film on this list, Troll
2 is that movie.
From the totally implausible plot to the fact
that not even a single troll appears in the
film, this 1990 no-budget disaster is a catastrophe
in every sense of the word, redefining what
the word "bad" truly means.
"Michael?"
"Yeah?"
"Who are the Goblins?"
The story itself follows a family who try
and stop vegetarian goblins from turning them
into plants, but that doesn't really matter.
What does matter is the atrocious performances
on display, which helped the film develop
a cult following that led to numerous screenings
at midnight movie festivals and a documentary
called Best Worst Movie in 2009 which chronicled
the many problems experienced on set.
While it's difficult to pinpoint the single
worst performance in Troll 2, the one that's
gained the most notoriety over the years comes
courtesy of Darren Ewing, whose character
reacts in horror at the sight of a woman being
devoured by goblins and delivers a line that
would become a viral sensation years later.
"They're eating her!
And then they're going to eat me!
OH MY GOOOOO--"
Sure, it's a bad movie, maybe the worst movie,
but there's no way to watch that clip without
having a fun time watching it, and there are
plenty of Hollywood blockbusters that can't
claim that.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.